[Music]
I'm gonna live a day without wildfire
good morning everybody first of all
thank you to Cisco for sponsoring
today's video they are coming out with a
new product that improves Wi-Fi
accessibility so stick around to the end
for the sponsors message so today I'm
gonna live a day without Wi-Fi this was
a challenge posed by Cisco and I'm gonna
try it out because looking in Silicon
Valley there's a lot of things that you
can do there's a lot of internet that
you access basically I'm always on my
phone and I'm always on my laptop too as
well as other connected devices that
other people have I don't really use
them that much like I don't really use
my my watch or I don't have a connected
fridge yeah it's gonna be fun but I've
been super reliant on this things I am
going to turn it on to airplane mode as
a way to not cheat so penny did you
Boop no internet so the rules for today
are to not use like Wi-Fi or data
basically I have a couple dings plans of
the day I'm about to go aqua Kona being
go to the gym I have to go shopping a
little bit and I'm never confident in
being able to get to the mall without
any GPS even though I've lived here so
every time we take you on a different
route so you never know I don't know
yeah we'll see how it goes I haven't
lived off the grid in a while let alone
in my own house in my own neighborhood
so we'll see how this goes let's do it
[Music]
I'm gonna leave my phone at home cuz I
don't need it
cuz I'm not connected to the Internet
[Music]
I'm so hot okay
back from walking Kona and going to the
gym I'm gonna take a shower because I
feel chilly gross before talking about
how that was without any connection on
my phone so see you in a bit
[Music]
I have my airplane my airplane I forgot
how to talk to the camera my phone has
been on airplane mode since this morning
it's kind of been okay like I haven't
neat found a use for it yet like the
fact that I don't have Wi-Fi or data not
entirely bad maybe the only two pieces
was like I couldn't look up the weather
for today I'd also like while working
out I listened to music that was like
downloaded onto my phone so that was
slightly different but luckily I I have
noticed though that I take my phone with
me everywhere even if I'm not gonna use
it I just bring it with I think because
just because I lose it
this is far so good turns out I'm not
just waiting till tonight you know I
have nothing to do I need the name boy
that's where a little strength
check out my pita bread oh so full from
lunch and tired from morning that I just
took a hour I just take an hour now
usually I would be on my phone on
Instagram or something probably but
instead I took a nap for the first time
in months and I felt good turns out when
you don't have technology you can do the
stuff that you want to do because you
have time for it all of a sudden at
least for now okay finally about to head
out I am going to probably two places
the first being Michaels because I have
to get something framed I think I know
where it is I'm just gonna take a spa
loli slower but a route that I know and
then I'm gonna go to the mall and it's
gonna be really crowded but I need a
couple things there so hopefully I will
not get lost there's always the hope
okay let's go
I think so far so good
I think I know where I'm going fun fact
though when Scott and I first moved to
the Bay Area we thought that the
internet here is terrible but also our
internet connectivity in general on her
phone was like so bad I think it's
improved a little bit actually maybe
because we like switched carriers and
phones are getting better but I think
also the infrastructure of the city but
now when we first move we were so
disappointed because we're like we
thought this was Silicon Valley like I
thought internet connection here would
be superb and that was exciting to say
the least
but things are better but yeah there's
still some issues in some spots I did it
we're here the sign is right there it's
Michaels for those of you not in the US
Michaels is a craft store that has a big
frame shop inside which I've actually
never used but I need to get something
framed for a friend's birthday so we're
gonna go do that but I'm very proud that
we got here I am also very worried about
getting to the next location because I
don't know how to do that from here but
you know we'll figure it up let's go why
it's not Black Friday though I'm all
done with Michael oh I'm gonna go to the
mall so it is a little bit embarrassing
how little I know the streets of my town
but it's also cuz I'm just generally bad
at directions
Scott is usually the one to navigate and
I kind of just follow you know like in
pokemon yellow
I think Pikachu just follows Asher out
wherever he goes that's me and Scott
because I cannot be trusted with
directions so let's see if I can get to
the mall
I think I'm gonna just go like back
towards home and then out again because
that I only ever go to the mall from
home and not from this part of town okay
you know whatever let's just do it so
far so good
someone thought that I just had right
now while driving was there's this
corner that I just passed by whether it
was an accident about a week ago but I
kind of wanted to like look it up and
find out more but I can't don't have
like like yeah I guess this is one of
those moments were like having internet
access is knowledge and knowledge is
Pizza Pizza is powered sanitizer sucks
I mean I'll check tomorrow but this is
one of those Velvets I'm like I wish I
had internet retail because otherwise
it's hard to find out about stuff
nowadays I'm here at porch okay let's go
shopping
[Music]
this is one of those security robots
that are all over like in
[Music]
alright I'm back in the car I am leaving
I didn't buy a single thing at the mall
today didn't find anything I like so
it's one of those days where he spent
like three hours at the mall you just
don't get anything because it doesn't
work out I'm just gonna go home to drink
some tea okay Oh finally homie it's 6:30
right now and I just got back from the
mall and it was so exhausting the bay is
just so crowded that it's like not fun
to like shop here at least personally I
feel a very strong urge to do some
online shopping now but today is the day
without Wi-Fi so because I'm not gonna
do that now that I think about it like
online shopping is like a blessing if it
helps me avoid those crowds like today
it's actually funny though because I
think that mall as well as like other
shopping centers in the Bay Area their
network connection and like their Wi-Fi
it's actually terrible
so there have been multiple times where
I am shopping and I'm texting Scott for
some opinions or I want to like look it
up or something and I can't cuz there's
no data this is Silicon Valley people
like there's no internet out there feels
a little bit ridiculous but also the bay
area is really dense when they're all
connecting all their stuff it does take
a lot of bandwidth and you're kind of
struggling for it usually at this time
of the day I'll like watch Netflix or
I'll go on my phone for a little bit to
decompress from whatever the day was
like especially if I come back from
shopping but my phone's on airplane mode
so I can't do that and I think Netflix
counts as Wi-Fi
I don't know what to do I feel like I'm
just gonna sit here and stare out the
window
it reminds me in like high school how
I'd be so bored during summers because I
wouldn't have anything to do now
the difference is I still have nothing
to do sometimes or I don't want to do
things and instead of just sitting there
I was on my phone this day is making me
realize how dependent I am on having an
internet connection for both the things
that I don't necessarily need in my life
like social media and stuff like that
and whatever but also you there's like
some things that I really need in life
that totally rely on a network
connection like being able to get to
places like trying to go somewhere I
didn't know where it was today I would
have been so lost like looking up things
about information about news about fan
facts and I'm just curious about but
it's like the whole like information
access is really important to me I guess
and I'm very dependent on it I don't run
into like a whole lot of things today
that required like internet outside in
the world because I think one of the
things that I sharp to do in my life is
because during my week it's so tech
heavy like I am always on my computer
always on the internet I try to peel
back on weekends and kind of plug out of
the world did you plug into my like my
real reality my day-to-day so I think
this whole day without Wi-Fi is maybe
going a little better than I expected
but also it's just amounting to weird
levels of frustration you know so thank
you so much to cisco today for
sponsoring today's video so the new
product that they're really seeing is
called Cisco Catalyst 90-120 access
point this delivers next-gen Wi-Fi
connectivity with support for Wi-Fi 6
basically it improves wireless
connectivity for users and device
is on a wireless network and the main
thing that is solves is that with the
increasing number of IOT Internet of
Things devices it improves connectivity
for those devices as well as a better
mobile user experience for especially
high-density networks especially for
places where lots of people are
connecting at once I'm really excited
about this because there are lots of
areas in Silicon Valley where the Wi-Fi
and data connectivity is just not good
and it's Silicon Valley like of all
places in the world you think that it
would be really good but because this
area's really done there's lots of
people and every single person has so
many different devices mobile Internet
of Things IOT devices this will improve
the connectivity when you get onto a
network with lots of those types of
people to learn more about the Cisco
Catalyst 9 one to zero access points for
Wi-Fi 6 there will be a link in the
description down below so be sure to
check that out and thank you again Cisco
for sponsoring today's video all right
so thanks for watching today's video
hope you liked it I have to get better
hurt blocking vlogging is still really
hard for me because filming out in the
wild is scary but if you like this video
let me know give it a thumbs up leave it
in the comments down below give me some
advice on how I can be better and don't
forget to hit the subscribe button for
more videos if you haven't checked out
my series yet please do so how to
kickstart your software engineering
career there's been a lot of great stuff
in there so far and more to come also
each video can be watched separately on
their own so don't think you have to
like watch it all the ones I think
that's it for today I'll see you next
time bye
you